if filmmakers ever score a three-peat a
part four is
almost always on the table here are some
of the biggest trilogies in movie
history
and just why nobody ever made that
fourth film
christopher nolan reinvented batman and
the superhero movie genre itself
with this dark knight trilogy the first
movie batman begins
showed how bruce wayne became a brooding
vigilante
fighting crime in the streets of gotham
city then the dark knight had batman
facing off against the psychologically
twisted joker
and here we go
and it all came to a conclusion with
wayne moving on in the dark knight rises
the combination of visionary director
and batman proved irresistible for
moviegoers the trilogy earned a combined
2.4 billion dollars at the box office
for studio warner brothers
and the demand for more batman by nolan
movies was there
the problem was nolan didn't have an
interest his carefully mapped out
trilogy told
a complete story star christian bale
told the toronto sun
when they inevitably came to us and said
how about a number four
i said no we have to stick to chris's
dream which was always to
hopefully do a trilogy let's not stretch
too far and become overindulgent and go
for a fourth
in 1998 a decade before the marvel
cinematic universe kicked off with iron
man
one of the first modern movies based on
a marvel property hit theaters
that film was blade starring wesley
snipes as eric brooks
aka blade a day walker half vampire who
hunts down and kills bad guy vampires
comic book movies weren't yet massive
money makers but blade earned
70 million dollars for new line cinema
who let blade 2 lose in 2002.
that was a hit too leading to the third
chapter blade trinity
which earned a relatively paltry 52
million dollars
according to slash film the poor
performance of the third blade led new
line to call
off plans for another sequel plus a
spin-off about the night stalkers
the vampire hunters in trinity led by
ryan reynolds and jessica beale
another nail in the coffin for that film
about the dead snipes
sued new line alleging that the company
didn't pay a miscontracted amount
are you out of your damn mind that legal
battle went on for so long that
newline's rights to the blade characters
expired and returned to marvel
which has a blade reboot starring
mahershala ali in the works
after years of sitting idle while
superman and batman got the summer
blockbuster treatment
spider-man arrived in 2002 directed by
sam raimi and starring toby mcguire as
the team photographer turned
masked web slinger peter parker after it
snagged 821 million dollars at the world
box office
spider-man 2 flew along in 2004 earning
almost as much
and enjoying widespread acclaim making
it one of the most praised
superhero movies ever made i want to say
i really i really like what you do
i think it's great spider-man 3 hit
theaters in 2007
and although it was a little messy and
overpopulated with villains and side
characters
it's still financially outperformed the
other two movies
spider-man 4 was a foregone conclusion
to the point where it wasn't just an
idea
it advanced far into production maguire
negotiated a deal to return
john malkovich and anne hathaway looked
to join as bad guy
vulture and love interest felicia hardy
respectively
and by late 2009 screenwriter gary ross
had nearly finished a script
everything was falling in place for
spider-man 4 to actually start filming
in early march 2010
with the sony announced theatrical
release date of may 6
2011.
[Laughter]
you serious but in january 2010 deadline
broke the bad news
raymie believing he'd be unable to make
a good movie in that truncated time
frame
quit the project sony in turn cancelled
spider-man 4
altogether and then announced it would
just reboot the whole thing for the
summer of 2012.
there had never been anything quite like
the hangover the 2009 film was as
raunchy as comedies get but it was also
a buddy movie and a mystery
three guys wake up in las vegas the
morning after the most
epic bachelor party of all time
remembering nothing
and the groom gone missing director todd
phillips caught something magic
and audiences loved it the hangover
became the highest grossing r-rated
comedy of all time
and elevated stars bradley cooper and
zach galifianakis to the a-list
how does the tiger get in the bathroom
he almost killed me hey bro you mind
putting on some pants i find a little
weird i have to ask twice
then hollywood tried to repeat the
formula not once but twice
as if the events of that crazy night
could ever possibly happen again
the hangover part 2 rehashed the first
film in thailand while the hangover 3
found the gang in mexico
audiences distanced themselves from the
franchise the third movie earned less
than half of part two
and was nominated for the razzie award
for worst remake
rip-off or sequel when asked by cenapop
if a fourth movie could happen
star ed helms pinpointed the odds at
quote
between zero and zero chance
james dashner's extraordinarily
successful young adult novel series the
maze runner comprised three books
the initial maze runner followed by the
scorch trials
and the death cure set in a dystopian
post-apocalyptic future
the action concerns a group led by a
teenager named thomas
none of whom recall the times before
they were thrown into a competitive
labyrinth that's a tool of their fascist
oppressors
we're trapped here are we
for the moment while the ending of the
death cure movie is different
and more open-ended than its literary
predecessor screenwriter t.s nolan
doesn't want to make movie number four
he told thrillist
we've actually talked about how much we
don't want to do a fourth movie
it's rare to do something clean that
just has a beginning
a middle and an end i really like the
way this movie wraps things up and ends
it's nice to let the movies kind of
exhale a fourth film
isn't too likely then although dashner
did write a couple of maze runner
prequel novels right for adaptation
the original back to the future wasn't
just the highest grossing film of 1985
it was a cultural phenomenon and one of
the most iconic movies of the decade
michael j fox and christopher lloyd
delivered charming performances as
wannabe rocker teen marty mcfly
and his improbable best friend scientist
doc
emmett brown marty accidentally uses
doc's delorean-based time machine and
winds up in 1955
where he has to ensure his future father
meets his future mother
while also fending off her very
unwelcome romantic advances
do you mind if i sit here no fine
no good fine good as time travel makes
the possibility for sequels virtually
endless
back to the future part 2 and part 3
found doc and marty
engaging in legacy preserving activities
in 2015 and 1885 respectively
decades after the release of back to the
future part 3 fans want another
installment
but not even the power of love can bring
about back to the future part 4.
screenwriter bob gale and co-writer and
director robert zemeckis have a clause
in their contracts
ensuring them approval on any future
future film
zemeckis told the telegraph that he and
gail are so opposed to the idea that
even if universal wanted to reboot the
franchise
it can't happen until both bob and i are
dead
released in early 1997 austin power's
international man of mystery was a
surprise moderate hit
as it parodied mostly forgotten swinging
60s british spy movies
written by star mike myers it was as
fashionable in the late 90s to quote
austin power's many catchphrases as it
was for austin to wear a crushed blue
velvet suit
oh behave the first film involved a
cryogenically frozen
60s austin out of place in the cynical
90s while movie number two
austin powers the spy who shagged me had
the spy travel back to the 60s and the
third
austin powers and gold member landed him
in the 70s
the standout character dr evil an
amalgam of james bond villains
also played by meyers trilogy director
jay roach told the independent
myers and i always thought there was
more to do with dr evil
roach also remarked that the pair have
long tried to come up with a viable idea
for a fourth film
but so far it's in no avail it may be
impossible without vern troyer
who portrayed many me dr evil's small
clone and who died in 2018.
roach said of the actor i don't know how
we do it without vern
we always had ideas of revealing a whole
life that he had that would have taken
his character much further
before star wars introduced the modern
era of a blockbuster sci-fi movie the
biggest
other world's film franchise was planet
of the apes between 1968
and 1973 five installments in the saga
of a world ruled by hyper-intelligent
ape factions hit theaters
planet of the apes is such a familiar
and well-regarded property that
hollywood can't stop rebooting the thing
in 2001 the usually wildly imaginative
tim burton helmed
a remake of the original starring mark
wahlberg the film was a hit but no
sequels happened
at least in part because burton said
he'd quote rather jump out of the window
than make them
instead fox waited a few years hired a
new team
and in 2011 rebooted the series with
rise of the planet of the apes
two more films followed dawn of the
planet of the apes and war for the
planet of the apes
and together the three movies serve as a
prequel trilogy to the original planet
of the apes saga
there might have been more stories to
tell of how apes acquired global
dominance but they won't be seen on the
big screen
in 2019 disney acquired fox along with
the rights to the studio's properties
and planned for yet another reboot of
planet of the apes
[Music]
please please help me
it's of nearly universal opinion among
film writers that the organized crime
pick the godfather is among the greatest
american-made movies of all time
based on a pulpy novel by mario puzo
screenwriter and director francis ford
coppola made the godfather a movie that
topped the 1972 box office and earned 11
oscar nominations
paramount wanted a sequel but coppola
held off telling mtv news
when they wanted a second godfather it
was just to make money
at the same time he was working on a
film that would tell parallel stories
of a father and son each at the same age
coppola finally agreed to make the
godfather part 2
and he used his framework telling the
tale of both vito corleone
and his son michael after those triumphs
coppola's career took a downturn
culminating in massive debts after the
failure of his passion project
won from the heart when paramount asked
him to make the godfather part 3 in the
late 80s he did it specifically to fix
his financial problems
it's not personal sonny it's strictly
business
but the film renewed his interest in the
franchise and he and puzo came up with
an idea for a fourth movie
by then puzzle was in his 70s and
concerned with leaving behind an
inheritance for his kids
coppola told paramount he'd do the
godfather part 4 for free if they paid
puzzo
1 million dollars the studio bulked
fuzzo died and coppola didn't pursue the
project further
veronica roth's divergent series was
among the young adult book boom of the
early 21st century
in a futuristic chicago highly regulated
and watched humans are divided into
distinct classes based on their
qualities and abilities
but not tris pryor ruled a divergent and
thus
dangerously unclassifiable i'm divergent
after the first divergent book came
insurgent and allegiant
with shailene woodley starring as triss
in the movie versions
adaptations of harry potter twilight and
the hunger games proved so successful at
the box office that studios weren't
ready to let these franchises go
so producers split the last books of
their series into two films each
giving the world awkwardly titled movies
like the twilight saga
breaking dawn part 1. allegiant was
supposed to follow suit
but the second part of the story titled
ascendant never did make it to film
after director robert schwenke backed
out and allegiant made half as much of
the box office as insurgent had
lion's gate canceled the film entirely
after lionsgate bought stars
plans were made for a tv miniseries to
wrap up the franchise
but those sputtered too in 1981 future
big time director sam raimi made his
first
major feature the evil dead a low-budget
darkly comic tale of five college kids
who visit a cabin in the woods and
unleash
demonic monsters charismatic and quirky
cult movie icon bruce campbell starred
as the hero
and last man standing ash williams a
role he reprised in remy's evil dead 2
a more upmarket remake and retelling of
the first belt
at the end of this one ash gets sucked
into a time vortex and winds up in the
year 1300
leading to the events of 1993's cheeky
army of darkness where he has to fight
undead soul-sucking monsters and the
forces of king arthur
see this this
is my boomstick in 2013
evil dead was released loosely related
to the original trilogy but more of a
remake and reboot
of the original with the action centered
around a new group of young people
terrorized in the woods
around the time of that film's debut
raimi's team announced that army of
darkness 2 was on the way
at a wondercon panel talk campbell and
evil dead reboot director
fetty alvarez said they'd really like to
merge the two trilogies with the seventh
film
none of those movies were ever produced
but stars
aired ash vs evil dead a tv series that
followed up the events of the original
trilogy
and in 2020 campbell revealed that
raymie was developing yet another
installment of the franchise
so maybe just maybe the king will return
to the big screen once again
hail to the king baby along with jrr
tolkien and his lord of the rings saga
c.s lewis virtually invented modern
fantasy with the chronicles of narnia
the epic tale of the mystical land of
narnia its lion leader aslan
and the conflict that tears it all apart
according to cnn
more than 95 million narnia books have
sold making it one of the most popular
series of all time
and yet it took until 2005 for a
large-scale
narnia movie franchise do not cite the
deep magic to me witch
i was there when it was written only the
first three chronicles books were
initially turned into films
the lion the witch in the wardrobe
prince caspian
and the voyage of the dawn treader in
north america however
each film made less money than the one
that came before it producers took a few
years to regroup
during which time the rights to narnia
passed from disney to the mark gordon
company which announced in 2016 that
production on the silver chair was
underway with a brand new cast
under the eye of director joe johnston
the film fell apart relatively quickly
because by 2018 the cs lewis company had
sold narnia's movie rights to netflix
somehow fox along with director sean
levy and various screenwriters got
three action-packed full-length feature
films out of the 32-page children's book
the night at the museum similar to the
storybook the night at the museum films
are about larry the night watchman at
the american museum of natural history
where exhibits come to life
every night yes you give me
gum gum over three films larry meets a
dinosaur skeleton and a monkey
along with several reborn historical
figures like amelia earhart
theodore roosevelt and a cowboy while
larry gets involved in plenty of
adventures and escapades
the fluffy and entertaining kids movies
plot a redemptive arc
at the beginning of the first movie
larry is an underemployed sad sack
by movie 2 he's a successful inventor
and by the third
he's left his exhibits in the hands of a
trusted successor and moved on
levy knows it's time for new things too
and he did when work began
on the secret of the tomb he told the
hollywood reporter
ben and i knew that the third movie
would be about the characters saying
goodbye
and us also saying goodbye and then
robin williams died after production but
wrapped before the secret of the tomb
hit theaters not being able to do
another movie without williams
or levy sealed it pairing a couple of
belize detectives who are very different
from one another is a cinematic
combination that almost
guarantees success joining the tradition
of lethal weapon came the rush hour
series
placing brash american detective james
carter with chief inspector lee
originally from the hong kong police
force do you
understand the words that are coming out
of my mouth
rush hour involved the pair rescuing a
chinese diplomat's daughter kidnapped in
the u.s
rush hour 2 found them investigating a
death at the u.s embassy in hong kong
and rush hour 3 had the detectives
tracked down a criminal mastermind who
happened to be
lee's foster brother all three films
were released between 1998 and 2007
so a fourth rush hour is long delayed at
this point
but it's not due to a lack of effort
after refusing scripts for seven years
chan finally approved one in october
2017 with tucker confirming his
involvement in february 2018
when the stars posed together for an
instagram post in april 2019
some media outlets reported the pick as
proof that production had begun
leading chan's management company to
release a statement denying that
as far as buddy comedies about two guys
who smoke a lot of marijuana and get
into
crazy and absurd adventures only cheech
and chong made more of them than jon
cho and cal pen the stars of three
harold and kumar movies
first they went to white castle then
they had to escape from guantanamo bay
and wrapped it up with a very harold and
kumar christmas
how you feel mr claus a little woozy
that's actually just the morphine it'll
wear off it's been years since the
release of that third movie
and pan and cho moved on to become two
of the most frequently working actors in
hollywood
likewise franchise creators john hurwitz
and hayden schlossberg are multiple
seasons
in on the karate kid inspired series
cobra kai
four principles with pack schedules
means a fourth herald and kumar film
isn't impossible but unlikely and not
liable to happen for years
hen said at a 2019 television critics
association event
they're busy working on cobra kai john
and i both have our own things this year
so i think
our hope is towards the end of the year
we'd like to toss something around and
see what might work
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you